في انتظار ما ستصدره محكمه العدل الدوليه
هذا الجمعه ما ما السيناريوهات
المرتقبه لهذا
القرار الفت اولا الى ان المحكمه تتخذ
نوعين من القرارات القرار الاول منتظر غدا
الساعه الواحده بالتوقيت المحلي هناك وهو
اجراء
احترازي او احتياطي يسمى بروفيجن ماجر كما
احسنتم بوصفه في التقرير اما القرار
الثاني الذي تعاود المحكمه اتخاذه بعد حين
سواء بعد شهور او بعد بضعه سنوات هو يكون
في اساس القضيه اذا نحن ننتظر غدا صدور
اجراء مؤقت يعلق مثلا العمليات العسكريه
يطلب وقف العمليات العسكريه وقف اطلاق
النار هذا في افضل الاحوال وربما ايضا
يتناقص الى ان يكون مجرد طلب هدنه او حتى
فقط امر بادخال المساعدات الانسانيه بالحد
الادنى يكون هذا ايضا بمثابه قرار ولو كان
اجراءا احتياطيا كما يوصف وهو ملزم هو
ملزم لكن المشكله تك طيب في الصيغتين
دكتور ابول ما الذي يترتب في حال الصيغتين
هذا ما كنت ساذهب اليه يعني كنت اقول انك
بطبيعه الحال تعرف ان قرارات هذه المحكمه
سواء كان الاجراء الاحتياطي المنتظر غدا
او القرار في اساس القضيه المنتظر بعد
فتره
زمنيه هو يكون هذا القرار من طبيعه ملزمه
اكيد لكن المشكله تكمن في التنفيذ ليس
لهذه المحكمه جهاز تنفيذي ولا تصدر هذه
المحكمه مذكرات توقيف او اعتقال اساسا هي
لا تحاكم الافراد هي فقط تصدر قرارات
للدول للدول المعنيه وبالتالي فان التنفيذ
اذا كان لابد ان يكون جبريا او اكراه يا
لابد ان يمر عبر البوابه السياسيه وهي
مجلس الامن الدولي وما ادراك ما لهذا
المجلس من تعطيل في داخله بفعل استعمال حق
نقد الفيتو المعطى لاحدى الدول الخمس
دائمه العضويه ولو كانت هنالك توافر يعني
لو توافرت اكثريه موصوفه من اعضاء مجلس
الامن ال 15 الذين يؤلفون يعني حتى لو
صوتت عشر دول من اصل 15